i really want to talk about feminism
right now oh yeah me too okay me too
[Laughter]
oh
all right you guys ready for this one
sure
get we'll go broke imdb tweets ahem say
it louder for the people in the back
she-hulk tatiana miss laney you guys
ready for this clip from the uh it's
from tiktok but it's she-hulk listen to
this
here's the thing bruce i'm great at
controlling my anger i do it all the
time when i'm catcalled in the street
when incompetent men explain my own area
of expertise to me i do it
pretty much every day because if i don't
i will get called
emotional or difficult or might just
literally get murdered so i'm an expert
at controlling my anger because i do it
infinitely more than you
i love this clip for this face right
here
all right all right spoiler alerts i
don't know how many of you wanted to
watch she-hulk but i do i like i love
watching the marvel stuff even though
it's like i didn't watch um
i i did watch a bit of miss marvel and
it was awful it was just so awful so uh
but we'll get to that a second so uh
this clip's great it's really really
great because as much as people are like
mocking the clip
it is masterfully done it is a work of
art
it is it is so perfect that i was i was
excited to see it
and the reason is
minutes
before this scene
she is outside of a bar we watched it
before the show i could explain to you
guys and three guys are not even
hollering not even cat calling like
i we were shane i was asking chad like
is this hot so the guys come out and
they're like hey what's your name and
she goes i'm i'm waiting for someone and
it's like well let us keep you company
because my boyfriend's going to be here
and he's like oh come on we're just
being friendly she goes
holds out and then gets ready to murder
the dudes she like winds up and then
hulk stops her from doing it
and so i was i was asking shane i was
like was that was that even hollering
like cat calling is when you're like
saying crude things below that it's it's
below that it's working up to a pick-up
line but you're not worried about it it
wasn't even hollering hollering bang
likes up girl why don't you come over
here they were just like what's your
name like let us keep you company and
i'm like it's it's almost hollering so
this is a parable about why women
shouldn't have power yeah perhaps
perhaps
but this is why i think
look
at that
there we go we got it the clip is
perfect she almost murdered these dudes
she winds up for like a kick and we know
from the show because they show her
throwing boulders and smashing a cliff
with her fists that a full force kick
would have exploded these men
here's what else we learn
in the show
when she hulks out with bruce
he tries to calm her down and he's like
calm
calm and she goes why are you talking to
me like a child and he goes wait a
minute
you're you're in there she goes yes
and you learn
that when bruce goes hulk he loses his
mind he becomes a rage monster when she
transforms she's fully cognitive and
lucid of what she's doing which means
when she's sitting there explaining to
him
that
she can control her anger she's lying
she's also a dangerous violent
psychopath and
immediately after this she says i
control my anger every day and then she
holds out
and then she calms back down
and so not only
is she lying about controlling her anger
in two instances here
she's she's she's lying like
it's the perfect example of feminism
exaggerating the claim
lying about their ability to control it
and then justifying that as why they're
a victim
brilliant if they say
misogyny like this entire program is
just like secretly
putting forward like actually
yeah if you if you like i'm watching
this and i i see this clip going around
and they're like say for everyone in
back and i'm like yeah but the context
of it is that she's lying like it's like
three minutes before she says that she
tries to murder some dude
and she's she's lucid she's aware she's
doing it
i'm like that's feminism
nailed it
and they if they define any type of uh
word as violence then you can match that
with violence so even them just
approaching them saying hey what's up
that's violence i i i dude i really love
this show already
uh she hulk's the villain
she's the bad guy uh so i'll tell you
something else i just it's just it's
really good um in spider-man why do we
like spider-man with great power comes
great responsibility man what a message
for a little kid especially for those of
us who want people to grow up to be
responsible regardless of who they are
what they do take some personal
responsibility the story of spider-man
you know if we if we'll use the movie
reference he does the wrestling match
the dude refuses to pay him then the guy
comes in and steals the money and as the
burglar is running away the guy's like
stop that man and spider-man's like
i don't see how that's my problem but
then that guy is running away
is tries to steal a car and he rob and
he robs uncle ben and shoots and kills
him and then spider-man is like if i
just stopped the guy
and took responsibility for my community
my uncle would have lived and it's like
a very sad message in this
hulk desperately begs her to use her
powers for good and she outright refuses
and says no it's my life and i'm gonna
follow my career and he says there's
very few people who have the power we do
the ability to protect this planet you
have to do it she goes no i don't she
beats the crap out of hulk destroys his
bar
it actually is a funny scene and then
they rebuild it together and she goes
i'm leaving he goes fine if you want to
just be a small-time lawyer like i
respect that she's like okay and then
she leaves
the point of the show is that she is not
she is refusing responsibility for her
powers i'm just like it's like what
you're saying will if the real message
was to insult feminism they nailed it
right yeah like that's what that sounds
like it sounds like kind of a
stealth you know refutation of basically
a critique of feminism is deeply selfish
right yeah
the hulk originally was like a chaotic
evil creature that was inside of bruce
banner who was like a new he was like a
neutral good guy so it was destructive
and and unex um unpredictable so i think
they've infused the uh
chaotic evil character into the woman's
psyche
inadvertently making her chaotic evil
you're saying hulk was kind of evil yeah
bruce banner would turn into this
chaotic evil no demon yeah basically the
whole chaotic neutral right yeah hulk
was destructively evil and dangerous
what are you talking about he lived off
of ray he's a rage monster yeah yeah but
he was he like he's he was the
protagonist so
that was the cool thing about it was he
was an evil he's not a protagonist he
wasn't evil well the hulk itself was an
evil creature that they had to keep
everyone wanted to stop it whenever it
would go so he was always trying to stop
it from appearing but he it would do it
wasn't it was like the hulk was just
amoral rage right like it was just he
would do good things
anger isn't really anymore i think anger
is is definitely a moral the anger can
be angry and injustice or you can be
angry at things just be angry like
someone kicked my leg on accident i need
to break walls
but think about that for a second you're
saying that a lawful good person can't
be enraged because that would make them
well that was the interesting thing
about hawkers he was two people he bruce
banner is like a good person and then
the hulk was this evil thing that would
come out of him and he'd be like no i
gotta stop
but hulk wasn't evil he was an avenger
the very original hulk was like this
evil demon with no personnel it was just
a rage monster and then they kind of
started to craft him and give him a
personality hero or something yeah yeah
yeah okay that makes sense like because
yeah i'm not really deeply familiar with
like the universe so i've like i saw the
avengers you know
yeah but eventually they gave they made
bruce the hulk one person that's my
favorite version of the hulk is when he
has a mind when he's like buddhist yeah
yes
chilling um i have some technical
problems with this show i haven't seen
it yet but when she in the beginning of
the scene she starts to tell him this
emotional thing and looks away to the
right as she's talking that's really
annoying to watch actors do that it's
kind of there you see her look to the
right it's like she's trying to generate
fake emotion which she glances to the
right right there it's really annoying
like you need a director to be like no
look him in the eyes when you're talking
well she's not looking at anybody's eyes
she's supposed to be looking at bruce's
eyes no no but like she's actually
looking at a big axe on a stick she
might have bruce in front of him working
they might be working a scene she has
her she has to look up which means they
would have bruce and he would have a
stick coming off his back with like a
green circle on it and she has to look
at the two dots on the green circle so
she dropped the ball there and then at
the end whoever wrote this this guy's
just ragging on the acting of the film
she says i feel anger infinitely more
than you infinite is not a multiplier
you can't multiply something by infinite
that's a zero so it makes no sense an
illogical statement of course ian has an
issue with the semantics of the
statement yeah the lighting is good
though
the lighting's pretty good so hulk's
like her mentor throughout this is that
the deal well he like kidnaps her or
kidnaps her oh man
she almost murdered a dude right and so
hulk thinks it's because she's that's
gonna be dan price's defense
yeah yeah imagine him hitting on her
sorry i had i had to choke her your
honor paul thought that she was a rage
monster like he was right
yeah i'm surprised he finds out like
good writing would have been him being
like wait a minute you're conscious
right now it's like yes and he would
have been like that means you tried to
murder those guys yeah like yo that's
that's crazy different discussion then
she just she just goes back to being a
lawyer it's like first of all you know i
said she was the villain right i mean
she's a lawyer come on you know how much
more villainous can you get they need to
make her selfish too
i'm saying that cause will's
lawyers do you think here good
oh i i mean most of them honestly
like what most like 51 percent i don't
know people
most lawyers are you know trying to do a
good trying to do good work and serve
their clients like now they're gonna
maybe they're in a position where their
clients are people you might find
distasteful like you don't but you don't
get to pick your clients if you're like
a big law firm for example you know i
mean i could have for example like i had
the choice well i i had some choices but
my choices were between uh bill cosby
when i was working in big law and uh
there was a guy who had a dirty money
episode made after him for running a um
a like payday lending scheme
that the ftc sued him for a billion
dollars over
so like that that's those are the
clients you represent because the
clients if you work at a big law firm
like and it's it's okay to not like
those people but like i hate when people
attack the lawyers for defending those
people and moreover it's like they're
they're dead that is your job right i
think i don't know if you guys watch
better call saul if you don't you should
excellent show um but one of the one of
the big themes in one of the later
seasons is how you know one of the
protagonists lawyers is representing a
bank client and then is also kind of
like screwing over that client to help
the little guys who the bank is adverse
to and it's like there's like there's a
bad lawyer that's a bad lawyer exactly
and that's sort of the point that the
show is making is it's like it's giving
you first it kind of gives you the
reason to sympathize with the lawyer and
be like oh yeah you know she's working
and trying to you know be robin hood
here but you the longer it goes on the
more you realize like no no she's
actually doing she's the bad person here
yeah because she is betraying her client
and like she eventually you know has to
leave her firm and all that i know
there's a bunch of jokes about lawyers
like i literally made one there's
there's one i can't remember but it's
like a guy goes to hell and then he's
like
you know it's like a guy sells a soul to
the devil and then he goes to hell and
he's like i need a lawyer and then
everyone raises their hand or whatever
the joke is i don't know but i actually
think most lawyers are good i actually
think the overall majority in my
interactions i have not actually
experienced the stereotype of a bad
lawyer
yeah i mean most of them are doing their
jobs and and trying to help their
clients they're expensive because
there's a cartel yeah that's one reason
and then they're i mean the worst sense
to get the to get barred and all that
stuff right yeah no i mean law school is
expensive it's not just getting bored
but you have to go to law school being
good it's you know costs money is that
the cartel is that you've got to go to
the expense of gotta go to law school
and then pass a bar exam right like you
have and both are usually a requirement
in most states so that that's what you
know i mean people come out of law
school 150 grand in debt and they put in
three years of work so it's like the the
starting
pay to just even hire a lawyer is is
really high not kim kardashian though in
california you don't need no bar well i
mean
in california you don't need to go to
law school and i'm pretty sure kim
kardashian went to law school okay like
you know yeah that's good so yeah but
like yeah california has its own weird
thing where you can like not go to law
school but pass the bar exam or you can
go to a non-accredited law school it's
kind of crazy how like you go to law
school to try and become like proficient
but then you realize having a big butt
makes you more money you know
it's true it's like a plus yeah
so it's it's crazy like on instagram
there's like i don't want to i don't
want to call anybody out cause i'm like
but there's like these women who have
they they let's say they do specifics
talents
like they sing or they uh they're skiers
or snowboarders
and then it's like i'll see the video of
you know them doing their skill but then
every other video is like you know busty
cleavage showing or like booty shaking
and stuff like that and those are the
ones that get most the views and it's
like well duh you know what i mean i
wonder what's the point of even doing
the other
videos if like in the end you realize
like where the i'll tell you i'll tell
you a better story
there was this uh woman on youtube this
is like six years ago i was i was at
youtube i was talking with google people
about this
she played guitar and she sang
her videos would get a few thousand
views if you go into her library you'd
see one day she went from like 2 000 to
like 200 000 on her video views and it
was amazing it's like wow she had her
big break she must have put out a really
good song
you know what the big difference was
between the video before with low views
and the video high with many views
cleavage cleavage
she started she started wearing like
like bathing suit tops with her boobs on
her guitar as she played and then the
views went through the roof i find it
unfortunate that the sex appeal has
become a gateway drug to the the true
passion of these people but it but it
works because they know they tap into it
and the second you post some cleavage
then they they get more views i wonder
if it matters i'm going to try it
tomorrow like like adele
right now
adele did not get big and famous
through like trying to be the second
she's a big girl yeah i mean she lost a
lot of weight yeah but she just made
really great music and that worked i'm
like
i i i genuinely don't know do these
women feel like lesser because it's not
the skill or talent that that got them
there it's a sex appeal or does it
matter it might be the competition on
social media because it's like when
people are mad at certain pop stars like
um like miley cyrus or billy eilish when
they start out as one thing and then
they mutate into the sexy thing i think
it's the the industry might be
pressuring them it could be social media
but it you know people hate it or they
love it because their their kids who
might have been with hannah montana are
now with you know i mean twerking you
gotta wonder like you look at the
kardashians and like do they care i mean
like isn't what i don't know which one's
the billionaire one like kylie or
whatever
one of one kylie jenner yeah kylie
jenner's i think there's multiple
billionaires in the yeah i think but i
think kim is you might all be
like i think she's like the youngest
billionaire yeah kylie jenner is like
the youngest bill yeah yeah yeah like do
you think she cares that people are
gonna be like you got famous off your
ass they're gonna be like she's gonna be
like
i mean
her sister got famous with a sex tape
right like like relative to her family
like she's like i was pretty
conservative but you know the other
thing too is like um i was reading about
i think it's kylie i don't know a lot
about the genders but uh
it's not just sex appeal that got her to
be a billionaire like it's it's legit
business they're also really smart
they're super sure yes that's what i say
like kim went to law school or whatever
you got mentored i think is what it is
in california you can be mentored but
not go to law school but still have to
pass the bar right like i don't i don't
think i don't think but i don't know
you'd have to look it up if california
actually has any requirement about
taking about going to law school right
right to be barred almost every other
state does that makes sense for
california i mean it's i think
probably it's risky right like the but
one the bar exam's not that hard okay uh
frankly and then two like there's a lot
that you actually learned in the first
year or two of law school the third
year's bs and it's like that's what
we've all seen legally blonde yeah well
yeah what's the
what's in the third year uh the third
year is like a bunch of electives that
you don't need to take
like basically and it's a way for the
law school to make a little extra money
off you like really the first two years
or what not
sounds like the lawyer should overtake
that and just chop it down to two years
well the lawyers don't care once they've
graduated because it's keeping prices
the prices are already high and they're
you know they're making money it's just
like once you're in the cartel you don't
have a reason to lower the bar and make
it easier for other people to become
aware my my experience with like getting
cast for the way you look is really an
empty like it's a i felt lousy whenever
i was in hollywood doing it if i got
like a modeling job and they'd take
pictures i'd be like i just feel empty
afterwards and like especially when they
start saying it and they're like we just
want to promote your sex appeal ian
you're so sexual i want your sex i'm
like god this this industry is missing
the mark man you want good
good acting good acting first is this
like a prolong is this that's not a joke
like you you you got modeling jobs yeah
yeah
is it more than one super bowl
commercial i was in one super bowl
commercials orbit gum commercial okay um
i did commercials did a couple of one tv
show aliens in america i did the pilot
of that show that was pretty fun we
launched that and then i did a little
bit of photography uh modeling stuff but
is there not a painting downstairs of
you ripped
yeah we should bring it up here
back in the wall it's like there's an
eagle holding it
replace this with it
the glare might be too much
it's like it's the stomach the abs are
too much and i think an example of the
emptiness is you see in the cosmetic
surgery that they i i'm looking at it
right now is this uh kylie jenner has a
cosmetic company so it's like cosmetic
the way you look of course the way you
look that's right that's right that's
the way you might try instagram is
makeup
that i in my experience leads to
emptiness on the inside but you know
it's a lot of money so you kind of just
pretend like it's okay and well my my
problem with
so as much as like
in the culture war they would call me
right wing i'm like
particularly left especially when it
comes to these ultra wealthy people who
use their money and just keep amassing
and hoarding and amassing and hoarding
and they're not doing anything that that
bums me out i'm also fair libertarian so
i'm like i'm not going to rag on them
and force them to do anything with them
money i just kind of accept the fact
that people make money and then they do
whatever they want with it it's like
okay well i wish they would do more yeah
the problem is
maybe it's better we're better off they
don't because mackenzie bezos decided to
do more with jeff's money and then she
funded a whole bunch of woke garbage so
it's kind of like maybe we'd be better
off if she bought a yacht with an
infinity pool instead of funding woke
racist bs right just as useless
like employ some people right like have
yeah well the card one kardashian kim
has a company where it's like um
like underwear and stuff like that and
i've heard from a lot of different
people that they love it like it's
actually really good and she's got a lot
of people she employs so yeah they're
doing something and it's not i don't
want to knock on just a sex appeal
because they are some of the ones that
are the always knocked on for how they
look but they're doing something thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you